when I was raising investment for my
startup a venture capitalist said to me
Ashwini I think you're gonna raise a few
million dollars and your company it's
gonna sell for 50 to 70 million you're
gonna be really excited your early
investors are gonna be really excited
and I'm gonna be really upset so I'm not
gonna invest in this deal I remember
just being dumbstruck who would be
unhappy with putting four or five
million dollars into a company and
having it sell for 50 to 70 million I
was a first time founder I didn't have a
wealthy network of individuals to turn
to for investments so I went to venture
capitalist the most common form of
investor in a technology company but I'd
never taken the time to understand what
was motivating that VC to invest I
believe we're living in a golden era of
entrepreneurship there is more
opportunity to build companies than ever
before but the financial systems
designed to fund that innovation venture
capital they haven't evolved in the past
20 to 30 years mentor capital was
designed to pour large sums of money
into a small number of companies that
can sell for over a billion dollars it
was not designed to sprinkle capital
across many companies that have the
potential to succeed but for less like
my own that limits the number of ideas
that get funded the number of companies
that are created and who can actually
receive that funding to grow and I think
it inspires a tough question what's our
goal with entrepreneurship if our goal
is to create a tiny number a billion
dollar companies let's stick with
venture capital it's working but if our
goal is to inspire innovation and
empower more people to build
companies of all sizes we need a new way
to fund those ideas we need a more
flexible system that doesn't squeeze
entrepreneurs and investors into one
rigid financial outcome we need to
democratize access to capital in the
summer 2017 I went out to San Francisco
to join a tech accelerator with 30 other
companies the accelerator was supposed
to teach us how to raise venture capital
when I got out there the startup
community was buzzing about I CEOs or
initial coin offerings for the first
time i SEOs had raised more money for
young startups than venture capital had
it was the first week of the program
tequila Friday and the founders couldn't
stop talking I want to raise an ICO I'm
gonna raise an ICO until one guy goes
how cool if we did this all together we
should do an ICO that combines the value
of all of our companies and raise money
as a group at that point had to ask the
obvious question guys what's an IC o----
I cos were a way for young companies to
raise money by issuing a digital
currency tied to the value and services
that the company provides the currency
acts similar to shares in a company like
on the public stock market increasing in
value as its traded online most
important I SEOs expanded the investor
pool from a few hundred venture capital
firms to millions of everyday people
excited to invest dis market represented
more money it represented more investors
which meant a greater likelihood to get
funded I was sold the idea though of
doing it together still seemed a little
crazy startups compete with each other
for investment it takes hundreds of
meetings to get a check that I would
spend my precious fifteen minutes in
front of an investor talking not just
about my own company but all the
companies in the batch was unprecedented
but the idea caught on and we decided to
cooperate rather than compete every
company put 10% of their equity into a
communal pool that we then split into
tradable cryptocurrency that investors
could buy and sell six months and for
law firms later in January 2018 we
launched the very first ICO that
represented the value of nearly 30
companies and an entirely new way to
raise capital we got a lot of press
my favorite headline about us read VC's
read this and weep our fund was
naturally more diverse 20% of the
founders were women 50% were
international the investors were more
excited to they had a chance to get
better returns because we took out the
middleman fees of venture capital and
they could take their money and reinvest
it potentially funding more new ideas
faster
I believe this creates a virtuous cycle
of capital that allows many more
entrepreneurs to succeed because access
to capital is access to opportunity and
we have only just begun to imagine what
democratizing access to capital will do
I would have never thought that my own
search for funding would lead me to this
stage having helped nearly 30 companies
get investment imagine if other
entrepreneurs tried to invent new ways
to access capital rather than following
the traditional route it would change
what gets built who builds it and the
long-term impact on the economy and I
believe that's way more exciting than
just trying to invest in the next
billion-dollar startup
thank you
[Applause]